it has been a busy couple of weeks for
North Las Vegas Police and tonight we
hear from a mother who has lost both of
her sons in two separate tragedies that
happen within weeks of each other good
evening to you at 11 I'm Brian Loftus
and I'm Denise Valdez eight news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough is live at
North Las Vegas Police Headquarters with
that story
Catherine Patrick is very strong in
talking to us this afternoon as she and
her family are reeling after losing both
of her sons Aiden and Adrian and she's
hoping that getting this story out will
bring more answers take a listen
adult pain in my body I don't know I
need Justice for both of my boys
Catherine Patrick describing the torment
she and her family is feeling after
losing both of her sons killed in
separate incidents within a two-week
span I literally just lost a 14 or in a
15 year old now all I got is two
daughters to raise the first tragedy
happening on May 21st when 14 year old
Aiden heider was shot and killed at his
friend's house party at the Craig Ranch
Villas in North Las Vegas while details
are scarce Catherine telling eight news
now that the shooter was someone at the
party who fired multiple shots hitting
her son in the back Aiden was found dead
on scene you know who did this
then on June 10th Catherine's eldest son
Adrian Hyder was killed in a two-vehicle
crash on Kerry Avenue if you had to pick
three words to describe your eldest
handsome
lovable
and caring Aiden was on his way to pick
up his cousin when police say one of the
cars burst into flames after being hit
North Las Vegas firefighters and medical
personnel found three people dead one in
the car that caught fire and the other
two in the other vehicle it's unclear
which one Adrian was in Friends of the
family feel North Las Vegas Police could
have given them more details on what
happened they need to get it together
and figure out what happened
the detectives need to call her we had
to contact the news in order to get our
story out there because again the police
is not worried about it
the boy's mother is now left planning a
joint funeral with hopes that more
details will soon come from police now
both Aiden and Adrian went to Canyon
Springs High School in North Las Vegas
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now